this is a production of Cornell
University
here's the beautiful Magnolia Sudan
Jeana saucer magnolias close-up by the
flower
it's a saucer like shape opens up this
beautiful dark pink and white flower
morning it's beautiful day may 2nd and
we have some other plants to show you
that are blooming here we have
rhododendron PJM and there were the
earliest sorted engines I have a
beautiful pink flowers here tubes if you
like and they are blooming pink and
purple all over campus right now red
engine PJM
nice Bank planting of rhododendron PJM
these plants are pretty old that's about
as big as they get very nice in the
early spring rhododendron PJM noticing
the rhododendron PJM at this time of
year it's all over campus and here's
another example right in here the
Statler
hi it's April 29
[Music]
[Music]
here's a spectacular old specimen of em
Alankar in the ILR courtyard this is
probably if not 30 or more years old all
tree large shrub is Emma lank your
species serviceberry or shad blue it has
beautiful early white flowers
can do what will in the Sun or the shade
it's an early spring blooming plant I'm
very very common here's a close-up of
enameling here flower the plant is
actually often multi-step as you see
here but can be single stem as well
here is karya japonica the early
blooming green stem shrub you look at
the flower and very early in spring a
really good useful plant for the shade
grows and blooms very well in the shade
here is Mahoney aqua folium it doesn't
have a long flower period but if you get
it early in the spring you'll see these
beautiful yellow flowers of Oregon grape
Holly and some damage because of the
winter on these evergreen leaves but
overall a nice early spring show for
Mahoney aqua folio
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu